[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
online capcom special program we're
about to begin
for
during this livestream we will be
welcoming guests from capcom's
development team who are ready to share
with us some
announcements regarding titles uh
resident evil village and
monster hunter rise uh wow look at all
the comments
so let's start with the first title um
we'd like to call tonight's guest
to the stage so over here uh could you
introduce yourselves
hi my name is and
i am one of the producers for resident
evil village
so for everybody watching thank you for
watching uh tonight
next up shout out to our viewers in
japan
and all over the world that was in
english but his name is peter fabiano
wow look at all the comments everybody's
really excited to kind of see
the information that we're going to
unveil tonight
so what should we start with
so today we'll be talking about resident
evil series especially resident evil
village
so we want to start by talking about
biohazard village
here's the latest trailer for those who
hey have missed it
all clear
chris what the hell
take him away
in life and in death we give glory
the bell tolls for us all they're
coming again
[Applause]
quit being so paranoid
long ago a young girl went with her
mother to pick berries for her father
who was hard at work but the forest
greeted them with a dark
cold silence the bush is empty
yet determined to find the berries the
rascal broke free of mother's grasp and
vanished into the trees
[Music]
mothers worried cries faded fast as the
girl ran on
over vine under branch
and into the forest
[Music]
it's just a local tale
if it's just looking window shop away
[Music]
wow that was so scary right
looking at the other comments it seems
like everybody is like wow that was
really cool
thank you so including videos we have a
lot more information to show you today
we thought we'd start with a summary and
some other information
to start with this game's story takes
place several years
after resident several evil 7.
just like re7 players assume the role of
ethan winters who's now living
peacefully with his wife mia
so uh that piece that he is living uh
with his wife
is shockingly shattered by chris
redfield who helped ethan in the
previous game
so after watching the trailer i'm sure
players are left wondering
what chris's motives could be and how
this changes the dynamic between the
characters from re7
uh we can't disclose the secrets today
but we'll continue to probably get more
information in the future
so in terms of the setting as the title
implies this game takes place
in a desolate snowy village where all
sorts of drama unfolds
so uh the interesting thing about this
game is the village plays a center role
so much of that it can be considered
another
main character and here we get a look at
some of the creatures that have taken
root in the village
as seen in the trailer they move fast
they're very violent and they
sometimes hunt in packs they'll become
even tougher when they're they're
organized and coordinating in there
but even in this creature-infested
village there are various residents
that the players can expect
what sort of story is going to be
waiting for you uh with all these
interesting characters
in village
so uh we'll have more details about this
as well but you know
you can look at this the pictures that
we have and kind of come up with your
own
ideals
so everything looks really cool right
like
just seeing it brings up all these kind
of interesting uh makes me imagine all
the cool things are gonna be happening
in this game
so is there anything else you can show
us tonight
so yeah we have something uh that we
haven't shown anybody
yet we have an interview
with pete and with uh the director sato
and with the art director takano so
please
but scary
for resident evil 7 we initially thought
of ethan
as a character who would just act as a
camera for the player
a
but from a story perspective we realized
it would be better to make ethan winters
a
character onto himself and you know like
we really ended up liking who ethan
became and
we wanted to know what happened him
after resident evil 7
like what sort of life he would lead
so we started thinking that for the next
stage the protagonist really couldn't be
anybody else but even and we
figured this all out at a pretty early
stage
we want to make sure village was just as
terrifying as rars in evil 7
um maybe even scarier but you know
something you'll probably notice that's
different from that game
is that we changed the lighting a lot
from what you saw in
resident evil 7 um you've probably
noticed that if you watched the pv
and you know we think we really hit the
a good
distance and made a terrifying and
beautiful village
and really grew them in scale for
resident evil village
not only did we up the graphics and
elements of survival horror but
we focused on making the world and the
atmosphere
all around it feel both beautiful
yet terrifying
so when we were making resident evil 7
we thought you know is this
still scary we decided that in terms of
game decide uh we would go back over
everything that we did and i didn't keep
this in mind
we'd go back and we'd kind of reverse
all of that we they think all the logic
we use in the previous games
and try to make a really uh you know
terrifying game
so compared to re7 village is a bit more
catchy a bit more easy to pull yourself
into that's one of the primary concepts
we kept in mind when creating the game
now in terms of visual beauty and the
weight we gave to it
i really left it all entirely in the
capable hands of art director
as village's director i tried to think
about the feel of the game like what are
the emotional moments where is the
terror
where's the beauty what's like where's
the cruelty
where are all these like feelings and
thinking about all that sort of stuff
is my main job what i consider my main
job in ice cream this game
now when we think of the word village uh
it affects a sense of closeness of like
a small
tiny place but when you look at what
you've built village to be it's sort of
a colossal distance it's got like this
colossal distant feel to it
we wanted to give it a sense of like
oomph like a very sense of reality
we did our best to make the mountains
around the village look as fantastic as
possible to really give it a wide open
vibe we wanted players to walk through
the
world and be like whoa i didn't think of
what i could actually go here and what
was so cool and everything
so we thought a lot about how to create
a game that you can make your own
approach too where you could figure out
your own solutions to problems that you
face
this is something we decided to do a lot
more with this game
so you have a lot more freedom than in
rd7
we want everyone to think of resident
evil village as a horror movie
that you can play it works really well
to draw you into the world we've created
you'll want to take your time to fully
explore the detailed environments and
the fully designed set pieces
the only way that you could make it any
more immersive i guess is
to scan yourself and put yourself in the
game where did you find this guy
give me a break pete hey i only work
with professionals
but the forest greeted them with a dark
cold silence
the bush is empty and into the forest
deep
[Music]
what is it with that creepy story
it's just a local tale
[Music]
that would be hard to summarize all that
and players might get
confused and think what's this all about
that would be you know not ideal
so we came up with this one storybook
that would sort of summarize everything
for people so they can understand the
whole picture
of the game to get the full experience
all the little touches and ideas that
the designers add are
fully realized and come together once
you make it through the entire game
this kind of story of ethan this one
guys
so probably the entirety of who he is
just kind of brought into a single
one single game
for the ethan winters that we created in
resident evil 7
i wanted to see where his story ended up
and i think that's kind of one of the
main
centerpieces of resident evil village
some
[Music]
you can probably see what sort of
survival horror we're trying to make
with
resident evil village
we're hard at work on resident evil
village
so uh and we're doing everything we can
to deliver an amazing game so
uh stay tuned for more information
so we do have one more thing to report
while resident evil village is being
developed specifically for next
generation consoles npc
we're looking into delivering the
experience on playstation 4
and xbox one as well
we're looking into it but we can't make
any promises
we will do our best in creating a
top-tier survival horror experience
on current generation consoles uh
hopefully be able to share some more
good information
wow that's really exciting right um so
keep tuned
for more information on this front
so that is going to be it for
information on biohazard
village but i hear we have some more
information to share with everybody from
something else
yes we have the 25th anthro
anniversary of the first resident evil
coming next year on march 22nd
2021
so we're here to kick things off with
this year
so we've created uh two mascots
for uh this anniversary like a cute one
and a really cool one
this one's like super cute right so the
one on the right is
raccoon [ __ ] um or you know
raccoon he is a uh the mascot of raccoon
city
now we have one more thing to show you
and that's this right here
wow look at that's like all the
characters so many characters i remember
from the
resident evil series
man it's been forever since this came
out 25 years is a long time right like
you know back then i was still student
when it came out and you know like
nike air maxes and stuff were out
beepers and whatnot
so i'd like to take this opportunity to
thank each one of you the reason why
we're able to continue this series
is because of all view of our fans and i
hope you enjoyed what we showed you
today
and uh we have plenty more information
here with you soon
so please look forward to it
so that's all the news from the two of
us today
so everybody is really surprised to see
that character in the middle of that
and that big uh
large picture they had a second ago so
uh next year looks to be an excited one
and do you have one final message before
you guys go and head off
so let's start with you uh
so we can only give you a little bit of
information about
this game right now but we want you know
that the entire staff
is for resident evil village is doing
our best to create
the best survival horror resident evil
game for you guys to play
so we'll do our best to keep making it
a sort of resident evil that is what
everybody wants
and is the sort of thing that everybody
can have a lot of fun with so please
stay tuned for more information
thanks everyone for watching we so next
up is
so uh we hope you look forward to more
information about resident evil village
and the 25th year anniversary of
resident evil
so uh that was all the information we
have for you about resident evil today
but
we hope you enjoyed it did everybody
have fun
i can't believe that uh papa the
character was in the center of
that big uh picture everybody was really
surprised to see in there
so next we have some information for you
on
monster hunter so stay tuned
25 years wow
anyway it looks like our preparations
are ready so now we're going to move on
to talk about uh
monster hunter rise and monster hunter
stories 2
which were announced just last week
so here to tell you about them are
monster hunter rise producer tsujimoto
ryozo
and the director
so could you introduce yourselves i'm
the producer
and i am the director uh
so i could sense the excitement building
up the moment you two arrived
there was all these really interesting
and fun comments people super excited to
see this
so what's your information you have for
us today
so we showed you a monster to rise
personal promotional video the other day
this is one that actually is slightly
different we've
we've updated the gameplay footage in it
so uh this is the tgs
2020 edition of it so i hope you enjoy
hey
[Music]
excellent
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
that was
we'll tell you a little bit more about
these new elements a little bit later
[Music]
that part in the end was like wow this
is super japanese right
i guess we're going to be able to expect
a lot of fun elements like that in the
next game
monster unto rise is the greatest game
in the monster hunter series
could you tell us what it's about
so our main focus on monster hunter rise
is
making use of the portability of the
nintendo switch which allows you to pick
up and play the game
at any time this game is about being
able to play wherever you want
whenever you want with anyone you want
so as we also explained during the
announcement footage the other day
the rise in the title refers to the
freedom of movement the player has
which allows you to jump and climb
around the environment
uh as much as you want
to players across the world while
they're exploring the game
uh we hope that players really enjoy
that sort of stuff
so uh ichinose and i will tell you what
kind of game
monster to rise is going to be and what
kind of features it's going to have
so let's start with the most important
aspect
the new player action
this game has all these kind of really
exciting
movement movement-based actions that are
in the game so the game allows you to
scale cliffs
and by kind of elevated platforms
and to use the uh the wire bug
to do all sorts of really interesting
things like
here's going to be a video showing the
wire bug
so this is some more actions that uses
the
wire bug
to traverse the environment
this lets you do all sorts of really
interesting things like
scaling steep cliffs and to reach high
places moving very quickly
it also can be combined with your weapon
for a variety of spectacular attacks
creating a completely fresh hunting
experience
so you can use the wire bug to do
actions like
wall running to overcome obstacles like
they're nothing
and to bring a kind of an exciting new
dynamic to the combat as well
as you can see there's cool combo
attacks
to make a much more fun experience
so the wire bug lets you traverse and
kind of give you a lot more mobility in
the game right
so we are really hope that people are
exciting to uh people are excited to see
more information about this
so uh we are talking a little bit about
the uh
there's a new there's a new area in the
game as well sort of
a central kind of place that you're
going to face off so after your quest
you'll head back over there
so uh we're going to talk about in the
trailer
we showed off a new locale called the
shrine ruins
we'll be able to show you some more live
gameplay of this area during
capcom tts live 2020 of september 2020
if that's tomorrow
um we're gonna have some actually
gameplay footage we're going to be
playing it on the stream for you
so uh definitely
put that down on your agenda so you can
listen to more
you could hear a lot more about that so
definitely make sure to catch the stream
on september 26th
man there's so much more stuff that
you've added this game uh next we'd like
you to tell us a little bit more about
the
new uh buddy the canine
so this is a new type of body called the
canine
they actively coordinate attacks with
the player
you can even ride on their backs to move
around and
do elsewhere so they're very invaluable
allies in combat
so while riding a canine
your hunter's stamina uh doesn't really
decrease
so you're able to run across each area
to your heart's content it gives you a
lot more mobility
so while you're riding a canon canine
also you can use some items and perform
some items like uh you can cover your
health and
things like that
so monster is a multiplayer game but in
single player
you're able to bring up to two buddies
along on your quest
uh kind of any combination that you want
so you can like have like a canine and
one other thing as well
and it's they can be two of the same
type as well so it can be two canines it
can be a canine and like a pound eight
or something like that
so you know if you're like dogs you can
definitely go with a dog versus a cat
scene or the cat version
so in single play you can bring two of
you but in multiplayer
each hunter only gets to bring one buddy
with them
so you can kind of like pick the one
that you know really fits you
so i'm really excited to see how these
buddies will kind of affect the gameplay
but now of course we can't talk about
monster hunter
without mentioning the monsters do you
have any
[Music]
do you have any new monsters in store
for us can you tell us about them
so monster hunter rise has lots of new
monsters
so in the church we showed off a few of
them including uh the new flagship
monster magna mala which you'll see here
so we can't give you all the
informations about magnum
yet
so we'll give you more fish as we go but
for right now we would like you all to
know that it's a fearsome
a fang with vern fanged with burn with a
strong air of menace
about that really it's scary
it's got some very unique modes of
movement so uh
sorry you're going to have to wait for
more information about that but we hope
everybody will look forward to finding
out more about this really cool monster
uh next up
we have a kind of
a very kind of peculiar looking bird
bird
that looks kind of like a parasol
it's fiercely territorial however and
once it detects any intruders
it spreads its wing it's trying to
intimidate
its prey by expanding kind of a crest
within that has an eyeball-like pattern
on it
[Music]
a bird will burn that kind of attacks
with its tail which has evolved into a
very
unique shape this sort of scythe-like
shape
so the great izuchi forms packs with um
others like it with other smaller izuchi
and it tends to patrol the its territory
with
some elite members of its pack by its
side
so once they spot their prey they'll
attack in unison
so you have to kind of stand your toes
and be aware of
the entire pack when they're coming to
attack it
next we have this very unique
monster called tetranadon who's an
amphibious monster that
he's a bit of a hefty chunk uh he's
extremely gluttonous
and it'll swell anything that moves
including the ground that it's standing
on
so once it's done eating its stomach
will swell and it kind of gets slower
but
then its attacks also become heavier and
more
destructive
so we have definitely several new more
monsters to
talk about
and we also have a lot of monsters from
that you know and love from the monster
hunter series
and uh they will all be in monster rice
but we can't talk about them just now so
please keep an eye out for more
information so
we talked a little bit about the uh the
new base that you start off in monster
rise can you tell us a little bit more
about that
so the base of your new hunting life is
called
kamada village which is
very japanese looking village right
it's got all the conveniences you need
like a
smithy facilities and
other really interesting buildings to
explore
there's also a lot of colorful character
characters
in this village who will be supporting
the hunters uh
as they explore this world
so the trailer also made something
called uh the rampage
it's really important to the story so we
can't
quite reveal anything about that just
yet
but this is a completely new gameplay
element that we're working on so please
look forward to more information
in the future
so we've talked a lot a lot and we
showed you this new pv as well
but that's about all we can talk about
today though
slightly different trailer that we've
made just for this occasion
you showed a slightly different trailer
just for this occasion so could you tell
us a little bit more about the new
scenes you added
so firstly we shut off
we showed off some new actions for the
lance the hammer the light bogan and the
long sword
and we also showed some cool new actions
that use the wire bug
there are also some really interesting
new aerial attacks using
large barrel bombs so um
so we also have new uh actions and new
abilities for
the pelicos and uh a
guarding parasol i think for a canine
there's even a glimpse of a small
monster with a very unique kind of face
that you'll
run into the shrine ruins kind of like a
tanuki a wrecking dog
we also show kind of like a bug like
monster as well
but we'll tell you more about those at a
later date
well i mean it sounds like there's a lot
more really cool information to be
waiting for
so we'll keep an eye out for it
some live
pacific standard gameplay so we hope you
tune in again tomorrow
i think we have just some of that
information on the screen
so now that we know a little bit more
about the game itself can you tell us
what we should expect at launch
friday march 26th 2021. uh it will be
released simultaneously worldwide
we'll of course have both a physical
version and a digital version so you can
pick whichever you like
we also have a version of monster hunter
rise
called deluxe edition that has a bundle
of recommended dlc
including the kamurai layered armor set
for more information about this please
visit our official website
are there any bonus things that we can
accept a pre-order bonus that we can
think of
so he comes in how cute those guys look
at so we don't have uh
that many supply will be limited
but all versions will include
and some special layered armor
so your palm will get a retriever
costume layered armor and your palco
will get
a forest cat layered out and god
delightfully cute that is
so we also have three monster hunter
rise amiibos that will be released on
this
same as the game uh magna mala a
palamute and a powerco
these amiibo unlock special layered
armors in the game so we hope
you check them out
and last but not least
we did mention monster inter stories to
the other week as well
so we have some cool crossover content
for that as well so look forward to more
information on that at a later date
so pre-orders to the digital version
have already gone live
and pre-orders for the physical version
started today uh september 25th
so uh please consider pre-ordering very
much appreciated
so everything we talked about today will
be put up on the official website as
well
so please don't forget to check that for
more information
so i think that about finishes
everything for today uh monster hunter
rise comes out on march 26 2021
are there any final words you have for
our viewers about this game
since monster hunter rise was announced
the other day we've received a lot of
positive fan feedback which has made us
really happy thank you very much
so we are currently working hard on
completing this completely new hunting
experience
so please look forward to it and to more
information about these
our game
so we'll keep bringing you the latest
info on monster hunter rise in the
future
but we would definitely have a lot more
to talk about before march 20th 21st
2021
so we've only revealed a tiny bit of
information thus far so we hope you look
forward to finding out all the
more information we have coming up
also please make sure to follow the
official line in twitter and other sns
accounts for monster hunter we will
continue to add more information
as time goes on
so that's all from mr ichinose thank you
very much for joining us today
more information on monster hunter
stories too with us
so at the same time as wanted to rise we
released some information we released
we announced monster hunter stories too
so i have some more information for you
but please take a look at the trailer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
man that character design was awesome
that was such an exciting trailer
so the genre of this game is actually an
rpg
not an action game
so just like an rpg game it'll have all
the things that you'll expect
so you'll become a
[Music]
monster hunter obviously you're going to
be alternator but you're going to
forge bonds with monsters raise them
become a monster rider and travel to all
kinds of places
[Music]
so uh moving on
so rathos have mysteriously disappeared
from the world
of monster uh stories two wings of ruin
the protagonist a descendant of the
legendary writer red
meets a waverian girl who has been
entrusted with a mysterious egg
the two set out on an epic tale
surrounding the wings of ruin
now of course you'll be able to
adventure with many of your favorite
monsters from the monster series but
you'll also experience a narrative
deeply rude in the bonds between
writer and monster worthy of the story's
name
now can you tell us a little bit more
about some of the characters in the game
it's still a little bit too early to
talk about most of it but i think i can
tell you a few things so first look at
the slides
[Music]
so some people might think this is the
protagonist but this is actually not the
protagonist
this is a character named red who is
a legendary monster writer
so please check out something the thing
in the palm of his hand uh this is
called a
kinship stone and it's used by riders to
deepen their bond with
monsters so the abandoned monsters
are called monsters
so you can ride them of course but it's
said that there are monsters with other
hidden abilities as well and you can
kind of collect and find them as you go
so this is red's partner
a rathalos monster
so red and his wrath are key to the
story and they're some of the first
to notice that the world has changed or
is changing
in the practice the protagonist is red's
grandchild
the protagonist is also a monster under
like red but they're only a beginner
[Music]
they may be a writer but they use
similar weapons to hunters and can fight
monsters
[Music]
you'll be able to customize their info
their details so you can change their
name and customize their appearance and
do all sorts of interesting
things like that so this hasn't been
announced yet the next thing we're
talking about
but but these are all different uh
things that your characters look like
these are all
uh characters that you can design
so i'd also like to tell you about the
weapons in the game uh in addition to
the great sword
the hammer and the sword and shield
so now i'd like to introduce you to
another character
[Music]
so this girl is a bavarian named anna
so in the moderator universe there is a
race that's different from humans called
the bavarians
some of their unique traits um is there
exceptionally long lifespans
she is one of those so
right now you're probably wondering why
uh has this girl anna been entrusted
with an egg by rafa
but um we can't reveal that yet
obviously
meeting her is the event that kind of
sets the
so meeting her is the event that kind of
sets the protagonist adventure in motion
and meeting her is sort of the the key
that sort of sets your adventure
and sets you in your quest to find the
uh the wings of ruin
so i'm really excited to see what sort
of story is waiting for us
[Music]
so can you tell us a little bit more
about this uh the
game release so the game release is
going to be uh in the summer of 2021
so we're developing it to be a game that
not just monster hunter fans but all rpg
fans can enjoy
also as i said earlier some aspects of
the game
tie into monster under eyes so uh
some some things that monster under rise
will tie into monster until
uh monterey story is two wings of ruin
so please look forward to more
information on that
wow look i i think that's all the time
we have today
we'll be updating all this information
on the official website so you can check
there for more information
so do you have anything to say to the
viewers in closing mr
so today we introduced two games muncher
to rise and monster stories 2 wings of
ruin
so we're putting out updates via the
official website as well as our twitter
and other official sms accounts
so please don't forget to keep an eye on
those
also at capcom live 2020 tomorrow
we will also have more information for
you as well including a live
uh we will be playing the game for you
live as well
so thank you i hope everyone's exciting
for monster to rise and monster
stories to wings of ruin i'm mr
tsujimoto thank you for your
presentation
so and that is all of the titles that
we're introducing today
but we do have a number of special
announcements from capcom
so a huge sale line of capcom titles are
now up to 86 percent off
several resident evil titles including
resident evil 3 resident evil 7 and
others are currently on sale
for players haven't played resident evil
7 yet now is the chance to play before
resident evil 7
village arrives also monster hunter
i believe generations ultimate oh
nintendo switch is now on sale
uh how about picking up to play with
friends while looking forward to the
rival monster to rise
we also have other really fun old
titles as well such as okami from our
older uh from our older past titles so
please keep
an eye out for more information about on
them
now next up we have some
information on the capcom tgs live 22y
live stream it starts at 9 00 pm uh from
12 p.m for just two days
on september 26 and september 27th you
can tune in for additional info on three
titles
three titles to just feature today along
with the devil may cry special edition
um and
announcing street fighter 5 champion
edition
we have uh after the stream of the
stream today we have the street fighter
league pro jp
2020 tournament first lag we should be
starting on esports x at 11 p.m
japan standard time today uh topped up
with international top players such as
the legendary play umehara
and the todai graduate tokido the
strongest players will gather to form a
dream team to
their set set on joining the league
don't miss all of this really awesome
stuff
wow that was such a really uh packed
broadcast we had today we hope everybody
really enjoyed it and
that brings an end to our program
tonight
for everybody watching date thank you
very much uh goodbye and we hope to see
you again tomorrow
foreign
you